Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est l'astuce du jour.
Alors je ne savais pas quoi vous donner comme astuce ce mercredi.
J'ai regardé un petit peu dans les commentaires, les derniers échanges qu'on a eu ensemble sur Facebook, Twitter, Instagram et tous les réseaux.
Et vous me demandez souvent comment on peut faire pour calculer rapidement un poucentage.
Et là me dis que c'est bien qu'on échange ensemble parce que de moi même je ne vous aurais pas fait forcément une vidéo là dessus.
Alors je vais vous faire une vidéo très rapide, sur ce qu'on appelle, la règle de trois.
Une bonne fois pour toute, vous allez enfin pouvoir savoir faire la règle de trois !
La règle de trois c'est une règle mathématique qui permet en fait de calculer  tous les rapports proportionnels
Dès qu'on a deux choses qui sont proportionnelles, on peut calculer un élément manquant sur ces deux choses.
Pas extrêmement clair ça, hein !
Pas de problème, démonstration !
Pour une règle de trois, il faut commencer à faire des cases.
Il nous faut 4 cases comme ceci.
Ici on va mettre les deux premiers éléments qui sont en lien.
Et ici, les deux éléments qu'on recherche.
Par exemple au moment où je vous parle, j'ai à peu près 1900 abonnés.
Et je fais environ 35 000 vues par mois.
Ça c'est beaucoup, dans mon monde à moi c'est beaucoup, c'est grâce à vous donc je vous dis merci au passage.
Maintenant imaginons qu'à chaque fois que j'augmente d'abonnés, mes vues augmentent à peu près proportionnellement.
En tout cas c'est possible, c'est quelque chose que je peux me dire.
Dans ces cas là, à combien d'abonnés je ferai 50 000 vues par mois ?
Et bien si j'applique la règle de trois, il faut que je puisse remplir cette case là.
Et bien pour le savoir il faut que je remplisse cette case là, en utilisant la règle de trois.
La règle de trois, elle me dit que si je multiplie ces deux cases là,
et que je divise par celle-ci,
alors j'aurai le résultat ici.
Et je peux même simplifier en enlevant 3 zéros ici,
et 3 zéros ici.
Donc ça fait 50 fois 1900, divisé par 35.
Ce qui fait environ 2714.
Et en utilisant la règle de trois je sais qu'à 2714 abonnés je ferai en moyenne 50 000 vues par mois, si on tient le même rythme.
Faisons un autre exemple avec quelque chose que vous connaissez plus que le nombre de vidéos ou d'abonnés sur YouTube.
Les soldes !
Intéressant ça les soldes !
Si vous voyez qu'un manteau est à -50%, vous savez que ça va être à peu près à moitié prix.
Si il y a un manteau qui est à -30%, vous savez que vous pouvez enlever à peu près 1/3 du prix.
Mais si vous tombez sur une réduction de 47% !
Comment vous faites ?
Déjà vous pouvez aller voir le gérant du magasin en lui disant qu'il n'à rien compris à ce qu'était le commerce en fait,
parce que ce n'est pas simple du tout 47% ! [rires]
Donc notre manteau, vaut 98€, comme ça, ça va être bien embêtant !
Et il a une réduction de 47%, on voudrait connaître le montant de la réduction.
Donc 100% du prix, c'est 98€.
98 ou 97 j'ai dit ?
Je ne sais plus ! Si ce n'est pas ça, je change l'exemple, ce sera 98€.
98€.
Et la réduction est de 47%, donc on veut connaître le montant de la réduction.
47%.
Donc là, il faut que je fasse, 47 fois 98 divisé par 100.
Ca fait à peu près 46€.
Je sais qu'il y aura à peu près 46€ de réduction.
Donc il faudrait que je fasse 98-46 pour avoir le résultat.
Mais il y a plus simple encore !
Le plus simple, ça aurait été de connaître directement le prix final, vous êtes d'accord avec moi !
Alors pour faire ça, je refais mon produit en croix, je marque 100% ici,
La réduction affichée en magasin est de 47%, donc je fais 100-47, ça fait 53.
Là je mets le prix, 98€.
Donc je fais, 53 fois 98 divisé par 100,
et ça nous fait à peu près 52.
Un petit peu moins de 52.
Et ça, c'est le prix final de notre manteau !
C'est plutôt une bonne affaire, je vais l'acheter !
Retenez bien en fait comment ça marche le produit en croix, parce que ça sert tout le temps !
Si il y a bien un truc qu'on apprend en fait, et qui nous sert tout au long de notre vie, c'est la règle de trois
ou le produit en croix, on utilise les deux noms.
Moi ça me sert pour tout !
Même en voiture ça me sert.
C'est-à-dire que quand je m'ennuie en voiture, je compte.
Je pense que ça ne vous surprend plus.
En fait pour m'occuper mentalement, comme je m'ennuie sur la route, je compte.
Par exemple je regarde mon GPS, et si je vois que je suis à 212 km de mon lieu d'arrivé,
je vais commencer à calculer ma vitesse moyenne.
Je me dis, je suis sur nationale c'est à 90 km/h.
Je vais traverser des agglomérations à 50 km/h.
La moyenne est de 70.
Donc j'ai 212 km à faire, à 70 km/h de moyenne.
Donc dans combien de temps est-ce que je vais arrivé ?
Bonne question ! Et sans regarder le GPS !
Alors je sais que je fais 70 km/h, donc 70 km en 60 minutes.
On va compter en minutes parce que là c'est plus simple.
J'ai 212 km à faire, donc 212 fois 60 divisé par 70.
Ca fait environ 181 . Ce qui fait environ 3H, puisqu'une heure ça fait 60 minutes.
Et là tout de suite on sent à quel point c'est fun un trajet en voiture avec moi.
Voilà, une bonne fois pour toute vous allez savoir faire maintenant un produit en croix.
Vous allez enfin connaître cette règle de trois qui est très simple.
Il suffisait juste qu'on l'explique avec des exemples.
Je vous rappelle.
Vous faites les 4 cases. Dans la première colonne vous allez mettre les deux informations  qui sont liées ensemble.
Dans la deuxième colonne, les deux informations qui sont encore liées ensemble , dont une des deux que vous ne connaissez pas, que vous cherchez à trouver.
Ce qui est important c'est que sur la première ligne on parle bien de la même chose.
Si c'est des heures ici,
c'est des heures ici.
Ici, si c'est des pourcentages, ici c'est aussi des pourcentages.
Et pareil pour la deuxième ligne.
Si c'est un montant, c'est un montant.
Si c'est des minutes, c'est des minutes.
Ça doit avoir à chaque fois la même unité de mesure.
Bien sûr !
J'espère que cette astuce du jour vous a plu.
En temps normal, oui, parce que c'était une de vos demandes.
Je vous rappelle qu'à 2500 abonnés, on va se faire un live tous ensemble.
Alors on va faire des choses de mentalisme, on va discuter, je vais aussi répondre à vos questions tout simplement.
Et on va peut-être se trouver un nom de team.
Voilà.
Il y a, je crois que c'est Axel qui avait mit ça dans les commentaires: "Pourquoi on a pas de nom de team ?"
C'est une bonne question ! trouvons un nom de team. On peut faire ça.
On peut faire ça au live, amis le live ce sera à 2500 abonnés, donc pensez à vous abonner à la chaine.
Vous avez encore le gros logo qui est en train d'apparaitre, avec l'affiche des "Hallucinations Collectives" du 28 mars.
Partagez cette vidéo partout, sur tous le réseaux sociaux, que tout le monde sache enfin utiliser cette règle de trois, une bonne fois pour toute.
C'est notre mission !
C'est notre mission ! Apprenons la règle de trois à tout Internet !
Rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !